a huge day for golden knights nation as
fans are allowed back in city national
arena to watch practice something we
certainly missed out on last year 8 news
now reporter bianca holman in the middle
of all the excitement the floodgates are
open bianca
from the parking lot to the stands here
at city national arena all parts were
filled with fans ready to see our golden
knights back on the ice
the golden knights take on the san jose
sharks on sunday fans are excited to see
them back on the ice this is a very
intimate opportunity that the knights do
offer to the community to bring us
closer to get us to let us know the
players and watch your practice and
everything it's a fun opportunity
this is literally the best experience
you're going to have in las vegas
regarding hockey fans were greeted by
chance and bgk members helping to build
the energy as players show off their
skills and even though some fan
favorites are gone folks are expecting
great things from our hometown team let
us be number one in the west and what is
kick butt in the um in the finals
hopefully like next year we're sorry to
see some of our favorites leave
many of us are heartbroken
but
we can rebuild a better team
and hopefully get that cup this year
now fans can attend practice on friday
and saturday before sunday's game keep
in mind that if you do come to city
national arena you will will have to
wear a mask or face covering bianca
holman 8 news now live local now